how well do you understand the viewer
how well do you understand
who you're serving if you think i'm just
blowing smoke please
keep ignoring it because this is the
game
getting started on youtube and knowing
what order to do the steps in can be
challenging if you're brand new to the
platform and you're not really sure
where to start
or how to get going other than just
start making videos
well then this is the episode for you my
name is heather torres and i'm your host
of the
think media podcast the number one
podcast to help you grow
your influence on youtube and then take
that influence and turn it into a high
impact and a high profit
youtube channel and on today's episode
we're going to be diving into a two-part
series over the next two weeks we're
gonna be breaking down the four steps
to building a six-figure youtube channel
i don't know do you want a six-figure
youtube channel well then this is the
one for you
over these next two episodes we're going
to be splitting up one of the talks from
last year's
grow with video live we have our
conference coming up in just a few weeks
or days depending on when you're
listening to this and we wanted to give
you a behind the scenes
a sneak peek of the type of content
you'll get at groweth video live
on today's episode we're breaking down
step number one and two
and then next week we'll dive into step
three and four
let's get into today's featured content
and then after that
i'll come back on and let you know what
you can expect for next week
[Music]
we're gonna be talking about rethinking
youtube four steps
for rising above recession and building
a six to seven figure
online business with youtube if we're
just meeting
um i'm the co-author of the number one
bestselling youtube strategy book in the
world
youtube secrets and my passion is
helping people get results
with youtube these are a few of our
video raking academy students
that hit that silver play button target
but you know
there is so many different definitions
of success
on youtube it could be that you want to
get your silver play button it could be
that you want to get your gold play
button
it could be that you just want to create
a lifestyle of freedom or just build
a tight-knit community there's so many
different goals and here's the thing as
we look up here
i have i want you at the start of this
session to be thinking different
about youtube you got to think different
about youtube and here's what i mean
this session is titled the business of
youtube
i want you thinking different if right
now you go oh is this just for business
owners
no we all need to be thinking like
business owners there's something about
changing our mindset from just being an
amateur in our approach to youtube to
being a professional
there's something about changing our
mindset from just dabbling in youtube to
dominating
there's something about changing our
mindset from just kind of treating
youtube like a hobby
to treating your youtube channel like a
media company you know jay-z said
uh i'm not a businessman i am
a business comma man
like you're not a businesswoman you are
a business
and when you change your approach to
youtube i think that's the foundational
mindset that we need
as we get into these four strategies and
really we've seen over the last
decade that this is a real career the
ability to
establish yourself on social media
platforms like youtube
find out ways to monetize and there
really is a process and an approach to
that
and we're going to be breaking that down
in this session now these are actually
the first four steps
of our framework we're going to go
through at our growth video live
conference over the next couple
of days on 10 steps for building a six
to seven figure
media business i kind of make i think
about this as like moves in
chess right like you you need to make
the right move at the right time and you
need to be thinking
about which move are you going to make
net next and what are the
10 moves of building a high profit
and high impact business that helps
people we're going to go through the
foundational ones right now but write
this down and if you haven't grabbed a
journal yet get a journal
number one this is the first step in
building a six to seven figure business
and going full time on youtube is
positioning
you need to claim and master your topic
claim and master your topic tell me in
the chat tell me in the comments
what is the topic or the niche that you
have picked on youtube but we're gonna
ask some powerful questions here
your your niche if you will your niche
we just had chris ducker earlier in our
grow video live sessions
and uh he was over in london sharing and
you know niche is actually how you
say it but here in america we say niche
if you've ever heard marketers say the
riches are in the niches
you know kind of rhymes you say the
rishes are in the niches
is that okay bad joke i'm a dad by the
way i'm about to be a dad so the dad
jokes might come out a lot in this
session
literally my wife sitting in the room is
minutes away from giving birth it might
even be something that happens during
this session
uh we'll see but but what are you
passionate about like positioning
these questions are going to kind of be
like at the intersection of these
questions
is is where you want to plant your flag
and
claim and master your topic what problem
do you solve
what problem do you solve what can you
do to help people
you know in 2020 it's been a crazy year
and i love that video that the think
media team and tony areola did to open
up
uh grow a video this kind of conference
2020 has been crazy
and our heart goes out we've had so many
personal friends and family friends that
have been so affected by the pandemic
we've lost people like we've lost people
we know and that we love
we've seen businesses disrupted of
course we're going through
civil disruption we're going through
health and economic crisis and political
crisis it's a crazy
crazy time right now but here's the
thing if you're watching this stream
you got to realize the world's got
problems right
but you're called to solve problems and
did you know that we can use
video to help people to serve people
to solve problems you know entrepreneurs
just solve problems for a profit
that's what really entrepreneurs do and
guess what the world has got more
problems now
and that's why you got to rise up and
start sharing answers just sharing your
way of doing it
you got to claim and master your topic
the world's got
problems your boyfriend has got
problems right your in-laws have got
okay you there's problems to solve in
the world right now right
and so what can you do right now to help
people with video i think about the fact
we're living through
one of the greatest mental health crisis
the world's ever seen
it makes sense because of the lockdown
and job disruption and whatnot
now we have the the possibility with
youtube to encourage
to educate to uplift to entertain
to help people de-stress it's powerful
opportunity
how can you help people what do you have
results in if you're going to claim and
master your topic you've got to be
committed to getting real results
and simply helping other people get
results sean do i have to be an expert
no
do i have to have gone to school for
this no it's kind of crazy that this
small town kid
college dropout grew and it grew up in a
city
more like a town it's a city now called
arlington washington
right and so like farming and
agriculture was like our mode of
operation
and i grew up in a small town and and
was able to just start making videos in
my bedroom and now
be having some of the results and i saw
that opener video i'm like who even is
that like what has happened
in the last few years but that's the
power of online video i never went to
film school
like all i've ever i've i've always
invested in my learning and my education
but no one ever
one day said sean you're officially
ready to start
you know what you have permission now to
start a youtube channel
no i had to just punch fear in the face
and start
not get permission from anybody else but
choose myself and just get on camera and
overcome that imposter syndrome overcome
that fear and so
but i had results because i've been
building it up over the years what do
you have results in what you've been
doing
what do you what have you invested in
what do you have results in and then how
can you stand out in a crowded market
how can you be different and then what
will people pay you for
this session is about making you
money right this is i love that
it's possible to have youtube be a hobby
have you to be a channel where we can
just share our passions and build
communities that's great if that's your
ambition
but if you look at the title of this
very video in this session
this is a proven path to building a six
to seven figure business
so if you don't answer these questions
at the foundation of your journey
then it's going to be potentially a hard
row road
of reaching full-time freedom of
reaching that goal of going full-time on
youtube
so it's a good question to say what will
people pay you for
and people will pay for a lot of things
but you got to kind of know up front
like eventually
do you plan on writing a book are you
going to do an audio book are you going
to do some kind of an e-commerce thing
are you going to do what are you going
to do
what will people pay you for so
screenshot we'll put them up one more
time screenshot these questions dial in
these questions
this is that positioning question some
foundational 101 questions
and then finally what business do you
want to be in what
business do you want to be in that could
be
that you know i ultimately want to be a
youtube influencer and i need to get a
lot of views
because i'm going to need youtube
adsense it's actually not my recommended
path
because that's a very unstable business
model even depending on something like
brand deals also good but like could be
very unstable
they could be up one day down the other
so as we evolve we want to be thinking
no what
business am i actually in building a
real media company
even if you've got a brick and mortar
business you are a media company
you are a business comma man right
like what business do you want to be in
and we'll go more into that as we go
throughout this
uh this is jennifer she recently hit 50
000 subscribers and she her youtube
channel
is sewing crafts and diy and she
went full time on youtube actually a
while ago now and
has been able to do that because of
helping solve the problem
of people finding budget sewing machines
knowing how to use their sewing machines
learning how to sew and different
techniques she makes money through
affiliate marketing
youtube ads she continues to scale up
she uses brand deals
it's a good example of positioning and a
good example of picking a specific niche
and solving a specific problem
this is uh sean chandler speaks
he is actually uh he has a movie review
channel
and i ran into him at a conference back
before the lockdown when we were
we were able to hang out with people
right and uh he came up to me he's like
bro thank you so much for your contact
content i recently went full time
i joined video raked academy and like
i've now implemented some of those
strategies and here's one of the
strategies i was like well bro what kind
of ways are you making money
there's a lot of different ways but for
him as a movie review channel check this
out
he did the it you know the movie it
right stephen king in the book
it so the new it movies come out and so
he does
a review of all the it movies on his
movie review channel in the beginning of
the video
he just goes hey this video is uh
brought to you by audible
you know one of the best ways to
experience stephen king's
it is to actually listen to the
audiobook
and guess what you can get a free copy
of the audiobook if you use my link in
the description below
and so check that out and then he went
and does the review of the movies
well when someone signs up for a free
audible account
you earn five to ten dollars depending
on what account they sign up for you get
paid
if they just do the free trial and if
they become a gold or whatever member
you even make more money and so he made
thousands of dollars even though he was
talking about movies by talking about
some audio books
you got to figure out what business do
you want to be in how are you going to
make money
and his positioning though powerful
niche of talking about
movies he's got the joker up there he's
got jaws up there right
and this is andrew finney he's in real
estate
so you could do this in any niche and
there's something powerful
he's got a smaller channel uh
19 000 subscribers at the time of taking
this screenshot but some powerful
breakout videos
it's really built his influence he's
making multiple six figures a year
he's in the top one percent of real
estate agents and he's leveraging video
and social media
to grow his business i don't care if you
want to do coaching if you're an author
if you're a speaker
if you're in direct selling or network
marketing if you're selling insurance
you've got to be leaning into video but
you got to plant your flag
and know your positioning
so what is your niche what topic tell me
in the comments
what topic have you committed to
mastering
and remember this quote from sally
hogshead that says different is better
than better
have you ever felt this way in 2020 and
beyond
that like man there's just so much
competition now
like like all these other these people
have already started though it's too
late for me it's not too late
you know what's crazy is that in 2010 it
wasn't too late but people thought it
was
in 2015 it wasn't too late but people
were like oh man it's too late
i just don't think i'm gonna handle yeah
and then into 2020 that's the same thing
that people are saying oh it's too late
oh there's sean saying the same thing
again he's saying just punch fear in the
face i've heard this before bro
good good job good luck bro i'm gonna
hit the dislike button on this video to
really
well i appreciate the engagement
actually because even dislikes help
raise the video in the algorithm
so please keep them coming but here's
the thing it's still
not too late to start to punch fear in
the face
and just get going but sean how do i
stand out
you got to figure out your difference
how can you be different
and here's kind of more of an advanced
strategy when it comes to different is
better than better you might say well
sean what do you even mean by being
different
well i think about these two this is
dave ramsey
come on get out of debt cut up your
credit cards and robert kiyosaki
i love them both couple years ago or
over a decade ago i read the book rich
dad poor dad any robert kiyosaki fans
anybody read that book let me know
how about dave ramsey total money
makeover come on financial peace
university
they get out of debt scream you know
let's go
and so you've got these two different
what are they both teaching
the same thing personal finance
money investing real estate
whatever get how to invest your money
how to do savings
how to get out of debt but from two
radically different perspectives
right radically different like i
remember i went to a robert kiyosaki
seminar once and he was talking about
how to invest
and this one of his trainers pulled out
a stack of credit cards with a rubber
band
and was like this is how we're going to
buy and flip homes i was like what are
you talking about
dude dave ramsey would have an aneurysm
if you just saw what you just did right
there
like my gosh on the flip side dave has
this completely like no debt approach
but they're both helping people they're
both serving people
but they both are radically different in
their perspective
here's kind of what i want you
journaling about right now what are your
values what are your perspectives
what are your what do you believe to be
true about the world and about your
industry that's
different that's how you really stand
out
and what is your polarizing point of
view because here's what i've learned
people really dislike the rich dad poor
dad
and guess what people really dislike
dave ramsey
like you need to get over the fear of
people and the fear of other people's
opinions
because anybody that builds their
influence they're gonna have haters man
anybody who really steps out and does
something you're gonna have people that
oppose you and disagree with you
you'd actually need an opinion though
to be disagreed with here's the reason
why you're not standing out it's because
you're not even actually
sharing opinions if you're trying to
please everybody you're going to end up
pleasing nobody
if you try and reach everybody you're
going to end up reaching nobody
you need to pick a side you need to pick
a fight both of these guys do
dave ramsey doesn't have a problem hey
dave i'm calling in uh
how you doing i'm doing better than i
deserve that's what he always says and
he's like
uh what should i do should i you know
i'm thinking about putting a new truck
on some debt though can you afford it no
i can't really afford it dave but i'm
thinking
i really need a new truck my other one
he's like well then don't buy the truck
he's keep saying the same thing and
people go man his advice is terrible
another guy that i love grant cardone
completely
disagrees with that kind of both of them
has got his own philosophy
the world is big friend but you need to
have your unique perspective your
polarizing point of view
to figure out how you're going to stand
out in the world zig ziglar said it this
way
don't become a wandering generality be a
meaningful specific
man you want to stand out this is the
first
pillar of the 10 pillars we're going to
cover four in this video
it's your positioning it's your
positioning
you got to know what you stand for and
watch how practical this can be
a youtube strategy you want to position
your videos to stand out and
get clicks this goes all the way down to
actually
specific social media posts and specific
videos
so here's one example this is the sony
zv1 anybody got this camera yet
new camera we did a video sony zv1
versus the canon m50
love them both strengths and weaknesses
on both sides
a really cool camera and so this camera
comes out
so we start talking about we love it we
love the camera we get our hands on it
though
and i put this video out this is the
first video we released about it
and here's one of the things i noticed
was as soon as this camera
there's been no other camera that i've
seen and i've been in the tech thing for
a while
that sony sent this camera out to more
people than i had ever been so the
coordinated effort
the day this like camera came out was
just like
there was like a hundred on on youtube
about it like i was you want to talk
about competition
it was just like everybody like sony did
a really good
campaign of getting this camera we got
review units that we have to send back
into the hands of tech youtubers and
video creators and things like that
so we get this camera and i'm seeing all
these people post videos and i'm like
dude there's no i'm going to break
through the noise on this thing and
everyone was like this is so amazing
this is the best camera ever did sony
finally do it
the vlogging camera that changes
everything and actually
all of the thumbnails and titles were
overwhelmingly positive
now i don't want to pick a fight just
for picking a fight stay
safe but here's the powerpoint that i
want you to catch you got to figure out
man how can i be contrarian a little bit
you got to figure out
how can i kind of stand out amongst the
clamor
if you want to get your content notice
your videos notice i think of this as
like the jesus strategy i don't know if
you ever heard he'd say like you heard
it said an eye for an
eye but i told you i tell you the truth
it's actually turning the other cheek
so he would actually say like man
everybody's saying this but i'm going to
tell you something
like the real truth and so there's
something about
having a polarizing perspective of of
challenging common thought
of going a different direction not just
making something up
but sharing what you really believe so
here's what i was thinking about with
the camera and here's how the video
ended up being titled
best camera for vlogging 2020 question
mark
hint it's not the sony zv1
and then on the actual thumbnail besides
the red arrow this is some tactical
stuff you can apply now right
zv1 hype because there was so much hype
so i kind of wanted to pick a fight type
pick a fight in the chat
i'm telling you you want to grow your
youtube channel faster grow your
influence you got to pick a fight
and here was my belief is that this is
one of the best cameras for youtube so i
was like okay that is something that i
believe
but for vlogging the lens is not
really wide enough in my opinion like if
you're going to turn the camera in
yourself and you specifically need this
camera for vlogging
it's so close but for vlogging the lens
is not quite wide enough
and therefore i recommend other options
so here's the truth of the video
it's overwhelmingly positive video as
i'm telling you right now
love the camera but the way i positioned
the video polarizing picking a fight
against all the other youtube videos
and the the proof is in the puddin 132
000 views and this one keeps getting
views and keeps getting recommended and
suggested why
look at the thumbnail look at the title
it's positioning my friend type
positioning
if you're watching this in the chat
here's some of the results we could see
there
video has grown by 640 subscribers
already made 1200
in adsense right of course there's
affiliate marketing and things connected
to it
but you can see that blue line and it
keeps getting recommended and it keeps
getting impressions and it keeps getting
suggested
because click-through rate because
of that it's intriguing because it's
polarizing and so here's a polarizing
power question for you
what polarizing and provocative titles
and social media headlines could you use
for your content
the best way to do this is to really tap
into what you believe in to tap into
your heart tap into maybe what you're
afraid
to share but what you actually deeply
believe
like wait a minute if all the other tech
youtubers are saying it's perfect
i don't want them to not like me do who
cares man they're not even watching you
anyways they got enough stuff to do on
their own
well if everybody else do who cares
about what anybody else thinks
you got to stop worrying about prison
pleasing people and share your
polarizing point of view
especially if you really want this thing
to work and you want to break out in a
crowded and noisy
world and so uh as this is just tip
number one we got three more tips
uh three more pillars what topic though
if you haven't answered the question yet
are you committed to claiming and
mastering
now that you've heard this the topic
that fills in all those questions what
business do you want to be in right
what are you passionate about how can
you help people is it maybe
you thinking about how to pivot your
plan we're talking about how to rethink
our strategy in 2020 in this new decade
and so what is your topic uh and number
two here we go number two
discover your audience's problems and
ambitions
these build on each other step after
step point after point
discover your audience's problems and
ambitions so you've number one you know
what topic you're in you know what niche
you're in you've planted your flag
next question is really discovering your
audience's problems and ambitions
sean this is too basic if that's what
you're saying that's why you're gonna
lose
sean like this is the same dude this is
the nuance at the highest levels
i was just recently on on a on a like a
business meeting on a zoom call
i couldn't even believe i was in the
room with some of the most influential
entrepreneurs in the world
and i heard a guy that's like at the tip
of the top of just
business and entrepreneurship share
something that was like
discover your audience's problems and
ambitions he said really the difference
maker and success
is how well do you understand the viewer
how well do you understand
who you're serving how well do you
understand who you're creating content
for
and how well are you serving and helping
that individual
and do you have a good market message
match if you think i'm just blowing
smoke
please keep ignoring it because this is
the game
these build step by step and so on a
surface level might be like okay cool
took notes
give me a tactic bro this is the tactic
this is the foundation of like
really building a real business discover
your audience's problems and ambitions
listen to what richard branson said
to succeed in business you need to be
original
but you also need to understand what
your customers
want here's a question are you making
video content that your viewers
actually want
like are you creating videos that people
actually want to watch are you creating
content
for yourself or are you creating content
to really serve and help people
are you putting the viewer first here's
this deal if you actually put the viewer
first
know what problems they have share
valuable content that's produced in a
great way
that solves that problem why wouldn't
you win
but here's here's the beauty of this
because the people that are tuning this
out
are losing and the people that are
actually going in
and investing and really thinking about
how can who would have thought
serving people actually solving people's
problems actually helping people
actually giving people results wow it
just works in business it works in life
it works on youtube
actually entertaining actually being
worth watching i'm not saying that's
easy to do
but does that make sense like when you
put the customer first now remember
we're thinking different about youtube
we're rethinking our approach
well i don't really have customers i
have viewers well think about it like a
customer
what is a good restaurant you ever been
to uh a store back when we could leave
the house remember that
uh have you ever been to a store or like
a like clothing store or like some sort
of a hardware store or something
and you walk in and there's somebody
there that's like sitting behind the
counter
right chewing their gum and they're like
on their phone
and it's like ding ding they come and
this is the look they get they kind of
like look at you
and they just like look down they don't
even like even wink or like do this or
say like hey welcome in
and and you're like you know they're
they're like twirling their gum looking
at their phone
and you're over here and you're like
you're picking stuff out you're like
looking at stuff you keep looking at
them like i do have some questions
but they seem busy like can i get
a hand and they don't even ask you like
do you need help this happens all the
time
like this has happened to my wife she's
we're about to have a baby
and she was like looking at some baby
stuff and she's like you want to believe
what happened
literally i like wanted to spend money
i wanted to give a business money
and people were these two employees were
sitting there just talking amongst
themselves
like annoyed that someone was there
in the the store to give the store
money my friends this is happening more
than you would believe in our content
we're creating content just for
ourselves are we actually there to
serve the viewer like people
want to give somebody money
every single day they do like people
want to spend money they want to pay
money
for things that solve problems i'm
hungry i want to pay money
to get fed i need some running clothes
and with some
like tank tops and some shorts that
don't chafe come on somebody
i want to find some good well-reviewed
shorts i want to learn some information
about how to build my business
save money on my taxes how to grow a
youtube channel i want to pay somebody
money to go further faster
people want to give you money
how to build a six to seven figure
business but you really got to
understand your customers
serve and solve their problems and think
about every person that visits your
content your youtube channel
as a gift it's a privilege that they
walked into your store
it's a privilege that they're perusing
your youtube channel it's a privilege
that you even have the chance to serve
that person my
question is what are you doing with that
privilege are you treating that
privilege
with the highest honor i love this quote
until you understand your customers
deeply and genuinely you cannot truly
serve them
you cannot truly serve them so how do
you discover your audience's problems
number one
keyword research is a good way to do it
there's a lot of good videos here on
think media and we're going to be
talking about that more
at growth video live over the next
couple days but keyword research
why are you creating videos before
you've done the research
like i wonder what i want to create
today which is fine if that's working
for you great
but what if you actually started with
what people were actually asking
here's a cool tool it's called
askthepublic.com
watch this if you look up here on the
screen
askthepublic.com i just typed in
leadership the website is
answerthepublic.com i should say and
you can uh you can type in anything you
want
and it'll bring up questions i know you
can't read these on the screen probably
but i'll read some of them to you i
typed in leadership so if you're in
personal development
leadership you could type in keto you
could type in tips for moms
you could type in nlp you could type in
taxes
you could type in stocks this is the
questions people are actually
actually asking why leadership matters
why leadership
training fails why leadership
development programs failed
can leadership be taught the where they
are the how the what
that this is internet data like before
you just go make videos and like i'll
talk to people a lot like somebody
that's doing leadership personal
development like i don't know what
videos to make what i'm thinking about
talking
is i'm thinking about talking about like
my secret leadership rabbit formula
about how like
rabbits you know i kind of use like a
rabbit analogy i like rabbits
and like and i'm like and i'll title the
video like how rabbits and i'm like dude
bro why don't you just answer the public
why don't you just answer the questions
they're right here on the internet these
are the questions the public's at
here's a hundred videos for you to make
before you even start worrying about
other content to make
and guess what happens when you make
these videos is you'll start attracting
an audience especially when you optimize
them right
and create good content and good
thumbnails and all the details of course
but then you actually get people in your
comments you actually get people on your
content
and you can start our leadership and
management the same
see it seems too too simple most people
wouldn't ask that
our leadership uh are leaders born or
made
there's so many questions on here one
video one title
one answer when it comes to these
powerful questions that's just one
website answerthepublic.com so that's
one way to do it another way
is survey and talk to your audience
survey and talk to your audience
sean what video should i make if i
really want to discover my audience's
ambitions and problems
here's a tip ask
like ask your audience
what their problems are and how you can
help what videos do they want to see
now if you think this is too simple
think media is about five years old
professionally like that's when heather
taurus
at the ground road so omar al takori
the early days we had like jay and ron
helping us it's about
five years old when this thing was like
moving into business mode
but then there was like five years that
was like 2015 to 2020.
it was like five years 2010 was when i
uploaded the first video on think media
to 2015 so there's like five years of
just me
figuring stuff out just probably like
most of you can relate solo creator
no heather taurus no opener video
nose lights no like led walls
like just grinding and so you got to
know like great things take time and
great things take patience
and great big things start small it's
like five years
and then there was like years before
that where i was even mastering my craft
i was claiming and mastering my topic
because i was doing video in my church
from 2003
to 2010 so there's seven years where i
was learning video
horrible at video i've selected pal the
first time when i opened up adobe
premiere instead of ntsc
because pal sounded friendlier it's like
it sounds like a pal
and i didn't realize that was the
european frame rate some of you don't
even know what i'm saying and some of
you are laughing at me right now
but in 2003 i was like okay how do i
start a premiere project
what are they what are these options i
don't know what a frame rate was i just
started projects
things look so janky and sketchy and
crazy
year over year step after step and so
you just gotta know though that you
gotta start you start building that
audience but eventually
you will have an audience to talk to and
they will tell you
what they want to see from you in your
content but here's another one
read comments sean
i don't got any comments how am i going
to read the comments you want to hack
check this out
read comments on other people's content
man it's one of the best things you
could possibly do because some of the
tip
top people you're watching are not
paying attention
let me go back to finish that story that
i completely got lost in
over the years i've been doing this
video
stuff now for 17 years
and we our team at think media we talk
in slack
and so we go back and forth as is one of
the places we talk and then monday.com
and that's where we kind of project
manage and organize things and we're in
there
and here's the thing with pillar number
two understand your audience desires
to this day my friends 17 years later
i still don't think we've got this we
are still like
i don't think we really fully understand
our audience yet wow there is still more
questions we could have more empathy
we could deeply remember that quote
deeply
understand your audience how can you
deeply and
genuinely know the person you're serving
so you can serve them so i'm just here
to say
if you've got this one mastered good for
you we're 17 years into this and we
don't even have it mastered
and i think that's probably one of the
reasons why we're winning
is because we care and we continue to
think
man how can we better serve you better
solve your problems
better figure them out make the videos
you're actually asking for not the
videos we think
that we should make but if you say well
there's no one there to even survey
guess what you can do you can read
comments on other people's content
because what you can find is that on
somebody else your competitor
your competitors people in your niche
you can check out their content
and see but people go oh but i didn't
understand that that's an opportunity
for you to make a video
oh but you didn't really hit this that's
an opportunity to make a video
uh i'm not really vibing with that like
you will get more insight from actually
listening and observing than you will
from
talking and creating all the time in
fact
you have two ears two eyes
and one mouth so that you can learn
twice as much as you speak
can you think about that the way god
created us
two ears two eyes one mouth that maybe
we should observe more
listen more absorb more learn more
so that when we speak it makes an impact
well now it's time to get your journal
out and start writing out the answers to
the questions that sean gave you in
today's episode
really think about who your channel is
for what is the outcome you want from
your channel how are you going to help
people and so much more
go back if you need to get to those
questions again but i highly recommend
taking some time out of your day and
answering
these questions now again this was just
part one of a two-part series
all from our conference grow with video
live
you can get tickets right now for the
upcoming grow with video live virtual
experience
at growethvideolive.com go there and you
can see
all of the ways that this conference is
going to help you grow
on youtube this year and beyond now next
week we're going to be diving deeper
and we're going to share real everyday
youtube creators
that are growing their channels with
simple strategies that you can implement
on your channel and we're going to teach
you how to turn your views into income
and grow your channel to 6 or seven
figures
so you can have money for the mission
shawn's also going to share how he went
from six months away from bankruptcy
to being featured on cnbc for making
over forty thousand dollars a month
just from amazon affiliates alone you're
going to get all that and more in next
week's
episode now if you've not left a review
over on apple podcast i want to
encourage you
after this episode to go there and let
us know what you have gotten from this
podcast what value
have you taken away or action steps that
you have
because this helps other content
creators on apple decide if this is the
podcast that is for them
and i love getting to read these reviews
every single week and today's comes from
dangerously faithful
they say the playbook for mastering
social media this
is the best actionable no-fluff
step-by-step
and inspirational content to develop and
then dominate the social media world
this podcast
closes the gap from where you are to
where you want to go in record
time it's like learning from a paid
course
amazing content well dangerously
faithful thank you so much for that
review
and man to say that you're learning as
much as you would from a paid course
means so much to me
because you really do want to make this
no fluff and actionable
and inspirational so thank you so much
for that comment
again if you've not subscribed wherever
you're listening to this podcast
make sure that you subscribe today all
right that wraps up this episode and we
will see you
in the second part of this series on
next week's episode
bye not growing on youtube learn the
newest strategies for getting views and
the best proven ways to make money
at grow with video live a two day
virtual conference
and you can get your tickets today at
growwithvideolive.com
you